you know what i had this down as gaunt
actually
okay i'm perfect again like i'm i'm
shocked i got some of these wrongs i
thought
i got them yeah i'm shocked you got it
wrong i thought it would have been
fairly obvious
uh i thought it was fairly obvious it
was just because you know what it was
because we got a conversation the other
day where god mentioned the word showter
and i'm like this gotta be gone
like a week ago it must be gone he's
trying to [ __ ] inception my ass
um yeah i mean what is this this one was
weird
because i thought the premise was really
quite attractive you know i thought it
was quite hot
and then suddenly things just started
happening where i'm like oh
i don't know i don't know about this
really because let me explain the
premise
yeah so a teacher who works at the
school
is broke i guess very broken very broke
but she has a very broken full-time
full-time you know teacher
obviously yeah obviously some pain the
dog seems like everyone else is managing
fine
so her genius solution is to ask one of
the kids
whose dad owns an apartment complex he's
a religious kid
to just stay in his house and uh you
know so he says no
because he's a very responsible chad
child he says no he says no to this
woman no no you're my teacher you can't
stay in my [ __ ] apartment yeah why
the [ __ ] would you
so she turns up at his door
naturally as you do when you've been
rejected just [ __ ] turn up at that
door
this is already extremely wildly
inappropriate for hr standards
yeah uh and just invite yourself in uh
and then she just starts living with him
and mad props to the kid pushes her away
and says no
like 10 times that has to be that has to
be
rewarded perhaps
you could only last so long yeah but the
fact that he said no a bunch of times i
respect that
right expecting you know he's respecting
the hr standards of the workplace yeah
frankly for a kid very professional yeah
i noticed uh i'm calling hr how did this
woman get this job
that's what i did write down um because
she's essentially just trying to [ __ ]
this guy constantly and i'm just
wondering like
how does she get this job what's going
on here what's
what's going on here corey did a sneaky
uh hand job under the
table guy from what i remember she
definitely did
did she yeah she literally grabbed his
dick out and started sucking oh yeah
no no that was the first time that was
the first time before that
even before she even came to his house
she's like do you want to touch my boobs
i'll let you do it if i get to stay in
your house no but she said like joking
yeah because she's like supposed to be
like a [ __ ] teacher she can't say
that
[ __ ] jokey leave this student it's a dog
wait can i have a can i have a beer
actually can you give me a beer as well
from the fridge and the beer for this
[ __ ] yeah i can't
i can't talk i'll talk about this [ __ ]
without a drink you can run out of wine
all right so so to explain
why i guess to give context to why i
chose this um
this is one of my favorite doujin
artists um
it's an artist called fuga and i don't
think
yeah i didn't know how well known he was
but this man
is to me the king of vanilla yeah like
this man's like his art is like i would
say like about average maybe a bit above
average
average it's about average but like why
i love his work so much is that his
like stories and characters are so
[ __ ] good
where there are some points where i feel
like i'm not even reading a dozen i'm
just i'm just reading
uh romance manga with sex scenes i wanna
i wanna agree with you so bad i want it
but there was so many moments where i'm
like
nah bro this ain't it is it the ancestor
the incest side story right let me
explain
the story first and i'll build up to
you're probably wondering
why is that incest in this story this
doesn't
no connor didn't even mention it says
why is there interest in this story
great question i'll answer why that's
interesting this story so in this story
like i said you know she moves into
his apartment for some reason he doesn't
kick her out or try to get like his dad
to kick her out but
he lets her live in there and you know
they both explain to each other they're
frustrated because they haven't been
able to jack off because they're both
always around each other yeah and so her
her solution is well great i'll just
make you not
yeah as any good teacher yeah
apparently so they start [ __ ] and
then it becomes a thing
and you know it's very honestly like i
will admit it's quite attractive
up to this point yeah it's done very
tastefully considering the fact that it
would be very illegal
yeah and very concerning in real life in
dojin form
very tasteful i thought it was done
really well i was on board i would say
the reason for that is because like
there's a good like 40 to 50 pages
before there's this first section
true and like it's done well it's like
you hear this premise
and you think okay i've seen dojos like
this before they [ __ ] with like the
third fourth page or something no they
there is like it was tasteful there is
44 pages of characterization
and that's the thing that that's why i
love this gaussian artist is because he
gives a [ __ ] about characterization i
i'll i'll say that there was
he definitely took the time and again
like i'm saying like you know obviously
in real life the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is [ __ ] weird yeah yeah yeah but
it starts you know you set the kind of
disbelief apart
and it and it was done really well i'd
say up to this point it's done really
well
i got what you're saying no i was just
going to say i [ __ ] loved this one
again i was i was honestly i was so into
this
i was like this reminds me of like an
early 90s shonen jump wrong call yeah it
does
like with like the art and like how it's
pacing like the characterization i'm
like
i [ __ ] love this i'm not just here to
hate you know
i i agree it was hot right yeah up until
this point i was like they're hitting
every mark you know yeah
they've done this about as tastefully as
you can a little was it chapter three
it might have been chapter two so first
first of all right we get this whole
like i mean the whole reason why they
[ __ ] is because uh
there's a rumor going around the school
that she's dating a teacher yeah and the
teacher's like like the vice principal
vice principal yeah
and the vice principal was like yeah
we're dating kid get over it
yeah but he doesn't know they're [ __ ]
yeah and she's like no no no he tried to
take me to hotel and he tried to come on
me we didn't [ __ ]
yeah yeah all right respect respect i
get it yeah
and then out of nowhere like like
[ __ ] randy orton slithering in
his sister comes into the play and is
like by the way
i love him i'm gonna [ __ ] him now and
then they start [ __ ]
and i'm like what is going on where did
this come from
why why why it's like it's like this
this incest was just like
allow me to introduce myself like why
did this why no it wasn't allow me to
introduce myself it came in like the
kool-aid man
yeah yeah yeah
out of nowhere they just start [ __ ]
his sister and then she leaves and it's
never brought up again
why why not right too justified to me
no no no i'm not i'm not justifying so
much what the [ __ ]
i [ __ ] hated the incest in this one
okay god what the [ __ ] was that the
reason
i [ __ ] love this one teacher student
relationship done [ __ ] tastefully as
[ __ ] yeah um
like this like okay chapter three he
like she doesn't [ __ ] the main guy
for some reason like there is just this
like one of his classmates comes in and
is just like
i've run away from home and that's right
he was
weird too this my sister is harassing me
yeah
to correct what connor said it's the
sister doesn't [ __ ]
the main guy it's just these two side
characters
who just ran who is the brother sister
who just randomly [ __ ]
for no [ __ ] reason i don't know why
he's the main character
it's the main character but let's chat
yeah yeah it's like the main character's
friends shows up and he says
i've run away from home and then he
finds out [ __ ] me
yeah yeah my sister's been harassing me
and then heath and then
so this is even more concerning because
it has absolutely nothing to do with
the main story right that's what i'm
saying his friend finds out
that the teacher and student are living
together and he's like oh okay
that's fine whatever and then the sister
comes along and was like
the sister comes to the teacher and is
like do you know where my little brother
is
i heard he went to your place or
something along those lines and so the
sister comes in and she's like
this is this is mine he's mine yeah and
then she and then
i don't even know who he is then the
little brother starts like and then she
starts [ __ ] sucking his dick or
something in front of the teacher and
the teacher's just there
being like all right you guys
this is why i was like i was like what
the [ __ ] was that like i was
literally into this headset meme i
learned
what is this like why do they do this
like every time you get into it
a random side story comes up there's
absolutely [ __ ] nothing to do with
the story
and it's [ __ ] i thought that side story
was [ __ ] hilarious
it takes you out of it it was funny
the wrong way was [ __ ] i mean i mean i
it was i it was so out of place for like
the rest of the dojo
because there's only one chapter it's
only one chapter it's a side story that
i don't know why this side story is in
here
put it at the end because it literally
it literally had no effect
on the story and the character they
don't call back to the characters
like i don't know why this side story's
in here but the point is like
the reason this is one of my favorites
is that the relationship the
relationship between the student and the
teacher
is like so well and it's just like you
you don't
you can never read a booga dojin and
just not come out
just like with a warm fuzzy feeling
i agree with what i agree what is what
are you laughing at corner
why why are you laughing connor because
there's there's a few there's a
god i gotta stop you right there i will
stop you right again there is one moment
where i was like oh i don't know about
that one chief
well she's like she's like guys i have
an announcement to the school i've been
[ __ ] one of the students and i'm like
i thought that's a good idea i really
don't think this is okay well like
it's completely in character though
isn't it like they've built her up as
just someone who just doesn't give a
[ __ ]
yeah but i'm thinking i'm sitting here
like all right all right i did it for
love i respect it i respect
i do yeah i do but i think about your
career a little bit no she doesn't know
she's just
yeah you're not employed you've
literally just admitted to a criminal
offense i
i'm pretty sure like in front of
everyone no dude she was just like i
love this guy so much yeah i'm willing
to say
my job your honor it was love yeah i was
like you've been sentenced to 10 years
that's why it's hosting as [ __ ] she
she sacrificed her career yeah to
declare her love
and i'm just like exactly i'm just like
this is a dozen i don't care
you know i don't care about the legal
ramifications she obviously didn't get
any
the point is that like it was building
up to a point like
what what listen i i will admit the
ending was somewhat sweet i will admit
yeah a part of me was just like did you
really have to announce it to the school
this is really nice because you know
that's the dramatic scene yeah
it's not like this [ __ ] wedding you
don't have to be like lord farquaad
you cannot marry her because i'm going
to marry
you don't need that you know it really
doesn't add anything you could have just
been like you know what i'll see you
after school
graduate we'll [ __ ] you know that could
have been but that's boring yeah
i mean i mean it was it was dramatic
yeah it was it was it was
like you need the job you need the job
you need the spice [ __ ] that's
the pog moment where you're like oh i
can't believe she just said that
like when he confessed to her and she
just went i know
i'm just like oh [ __ ] son she did not
just say that
what i mean she's literally been [ __ ]
riding this boy's dick for 10 months
of course she likes her that's that's
how this [ __ ] goes but that's what i
loved about this dungeon is that it
reads like a 90s
rom-com because there's so many moments
like that in 90s rom-coms that i've read
where i'm just like i mean of course
like
like of course i was i was so [ __ ]
invested in these characters
in this character's relationship more so
than like any other dojin
i've read apart from his other works
like the i mean the only reason i really
chose this was
of course gant teacher student
relationship of course i'm gonna [ __ ]
love that
i mean you know it's taboo as it is in
real life it's very attractive
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fictional
works i don't think about the legal
ramifications whenever we do
sometimes i do i'm sitting there and i'm
like [ __ ] dude like how many years am i
getting for this
yeah like this this isn't even his like
most highly rated works there's there's
like one which i would say is like the
children of hentai if you remember the
children it's like an anime that
focuses on different couples kind of
like and getting together and it's
wholesome as [ __ ]
and his work is basically like that but
just with the [ __ ]
included right you get the same kind of
character development you can get the
same kind of
care in the characterization as you
would in any other [ __ ] monk i would
say there was
big props to you know making me actually
give a [ __ ] about the story
yeah uh despite the weird side story
again
i really want to know what the thought
process was i'd love to be here i
thought
in the board meeting i wish i was there
actually yeah i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious
it was but i was like halfway through
reading this chapter i was like
i know this is gonna happen no
ramifications on the story but it's just
hilarious to read
i was just like because i knew when i
recommended this that it was it was that
scene that was going to get brought up
and then of course how could i not i
knew it was just i knew it was just
going to be the moment where it's just
like
go on this your man i'm just like this
this this is not my man
literally this is not my mom get your
man i'll get you man
what i'm saying right is that two out of
three have incest gone
what's up with that what's up with that
you know whatever
he's just he likes it man don't leave
the man i like it because i get to be
the judge during an executioner here and
i don't have to
i don't have to share my taste he didn't
have to show your taste i don't have any
taste oh we roasted you enough
time come on
stand by my words but yeah i mean out of
ten
what do i give it out of 10 let's look
at what i gave it ah
seven out of ten oh not bad i thought
the good moments were very very good
the story was pretty damn good yeah a
few moments where i thought ah
yeah all right whatever yeah and a few
moments where i'm like all right
a little too much keenness from this
lady in the start i'm like
there's no why are you into this kid is
there any extra any reason why is it
purely
i don't think i don't i don't even think
she was into the kid at first really
right
because she's just joshing around yeah
she'll because i can't we'll get a woman
josh
he gotta [ __ ] around live in your
apartment bruh she's like she's like
early twenties
like she doesn't get [ __ ] like the
reason that like there was like she used
they used the cat analogy so much was
because she would just
basically was a stray cat yeah that was
like the analogy
right when i'm just like she she doesn't
give a [ __ ] a good story though it was
the first time where i read a dozen and
i looked at like a character and i was
like
you're not even hot you're just cute as
[ __ ] yeah honestly the reason the reason
this is my favorite of his works is
because
i [ __ ] like you at the cutest [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing the teacher's
like i love the [ __ ] teacher yeah i
think she's cute as [ __ ] yeah she's cute
[ __ ] fangirls the fangs like that's
for me